one thing does important we were talking
about this now and I received some
emails and tweets today why do you think
the left joins up with Islam so much
when they all their values fly in the
face of things that leftists claim they
support I think it comes down to control
I think there are a lot of people out
there who don't know a lot of Bernie
people a lot of Hillary people a lot of
people out there who aren't malicious
who bought into the lie right they think
they want to be tolerant many people
probably believe genuinely that
Christian conservative Republicans are
more of a problem than Islam there are a
lot of people out there who have bought
that and and I blame them for not being
educated but I don't think they're
malicious
then there are people like Hillary
Clinton then there are people like
Bernie Sanders like Barack Obama
obviously they know better they've had
their homeland security briefings
obviously they understand the evil that
is straight from the pit of hell or
whatever you believe that is Islam but
for political expediency they have to
keep their constituency in the dark so
there are two groups of people but I
think it comes down to control and Islam
is a big system of control leftist want
control and the way to control people is
to what's the easiest way to control
people obviously can get into the
physical taking firearms away from a
populace but before people I'm not
saying that all liberals are like Hitler
before any regime so there's Hitler
whether it's Mao whether it's Stalin
this is why the First Amendment is so
important right we're not just talking
about the ability to protect yourself
with the Second Amendment the first
thing they do and the thing they secure
more than anything else is controlling
information it's why Cuba doesn't have a
free press or Venezuela of course I
don't think Nazi Germany had a Free
Press
so I do think it comes down to control
otherwise it's unjustifiable it's unjust
there's no way for the two to mesh
progressivism liberalism whatever you
want to call it in Islam here's
something else I think that is important
listen I'm generally a non
interventionist like I said I think the
main point should be if we go into a
country you go in to win you kill their
leaders you break stuff you end it
that's what I think if the United States
is going in you go in if you're in a
fight you're in the fight at that point
otherwise don't do it so yeah I think
the United States needs
be selfish when it comes to that what I
do hope people take into consideration
though is the lie that the United States
is this evil empire and we're just going
over there we're nation building and
this is bullcrap the United States is
the biggest empire there is let me
explain to you
you obviously know Isis where they burn
people alive in cages where they rip
people's heads off where they they cut
their tongues out of their body while
they're alive and they cut their eyes
out and their arms and their legs in
North Korea the level to which they
brutalize Christian dissidents is
unbelievable from public humiliation to
just you know just woodchips up the
thumbs seesaw abortions forced abortions
for those who don't know what it is in
North Korea
seesaw abortion if you have children
listening I would advise you cover their
ears or turn down the radio right now
this happened in North Korean prison
camps just because you want to say well
listen the United States has no business
there maybe but let's not act like
there's a moral equivalency they will
take a pregnant woman of course if
you're a Christian and put a board on
earn people will do a seesaw on the
pregnant woman until there's a forced
abortion really really evil stuff that
they have to proactively think about let
me tell you something that woman getting
a forced abortion in North Korean prison
camp her only hope is seeing American
troops coming over that hill
she's not waiting on the British she's
not waiting on the Turkish she's not
waiting on the French her only hope in
life is that the United States decide
enough is enough am I saying that makes
it the United States job no I'm not what
I'm saying you need to understand it
from their perspective
before you start vilifying American
troops and conservative Americans who
believe that we have power and in great
responsibility that comes with that man
being burned alive in a cage by Isis his
only hope is only prayer is American Air
Force jets or Navy Jets coming over and
in dropping an ungodly firestorm on
these terrorists evil horrendous bags of
human scum that's their only hope so you
need to understand this I'm not saying
it's our job when we go off and act as
though the United States is taking their
oil let's put this into context these
people are facing brutal torture
oppressive regimes they have no rights
those people guarantee you ask them what
do you want to see it would be be
rescued by the American
it's their only hope because we're the
only ones who can do it does it mean
it's our job no but there is some
responsibility that comes with being a
country the only country who's had its
crap together for decades I just put
that into context next time someone
tries to act as though the United States
is no better than Isis this clip it's
taken from the full-length podcast every
week you can click that box down below
to watch the full free video casts or
subscribe on iTunes to watch them to go
click my face to go to Ladder with
credit calm when we write plenty of
articles columns and upset those who are
easily triggered or click below me
there's some other video down there I
don't know what it is yet not gay jared
is going to toss it's probably going to
be something ambiguous but uncomfortable